britain's vaccine will come from here a
pfizer plant on a belgian industrial
estate
in a place called purrs it is a big
factory
in a small town but a vaccine developed
in germany
is being produced here we've already
manufactured it
um and we're um packing
right now the first vaccine
worldwide delivered to the uk there's
already reports saying it could be in
britain
as soon as tomorrow is that
optimistic or is that feasible i don't
honestly know the specific details of uh
which laurier watch time and whether we
ship it by air but i think that's
perfectly possible
this facility will produce vaccines for
countries across europe so far
it is only the uk that's authorized its
use
which means britain gets it first
fighter have already manufactured more
than 20 million doses of this
long-awaited vaccine and now the
countdown
starts before they begin to leave this
factory
and head over to the uk today there were
murmurs of discontent from europe's
health ministers
suspicious that the uk has rushed
through its approval
something rejected by the government and
by the vaccine's creators
i would not see this as why was mhra
faster i would just i would rather
see this as how fast were regulators
in general and as we expect decisions
and that other
authorities come back to us within the
next couple of weeks
we have to say they all have been highly
committed and engaged
pers is a small town but now the focus
of global attention
here there's pride about its place on
the world stage
i'm really excited that they're doing it
it's small time now in belgium so now
they know it all over the world
perhaps eh with in a
few months it will be finished that
and we can do it
so we can live normally
down the road these freezer boxes are
being prepared to stall the vaccine at
super low temperatures
most doses will be transported by road
or air the company insists
it can deal with any brexit disruption
in pairs like everywhere else there is a
sense of anticipation
a hope that an arduous year may end
on a much happier note adam parsons sky
news
purrs